diese woche sprechen wir bei easyjet
über berufe ich möchte gerne von den
leuten auf den straßen wissen welchen
beruf sie haben und wie sie zu diesem
beruf gekommen sind den sie haben
los geht's
[Musik]
was sind sie zum beruf bildhauerin was
sind sie von beruf erzieherin
grundschullehrerin designer an
und was die seinen sie also grafik
design drucksachen broschüren
schauspieler und wen erzielen sie
grundschulkinder ich bin germanistin
promotionsstudenten und was werden sie
vom beruf wenn sie ihr studium
abschließen
ich will vielleicht im verlag arbeiten
oder als pressesprecherin mal gucken was
sind sie vom beruf chemiker ich arbeite
in einem sozialen projekt ich bin
schüler was ist deine schule ein
gymnasium in genau ich bin studentin und
was studierst ich studiere vwl an der
humboldt ich bin kuratoren und
wissenschaftlerin
ich bin studentin was studieren
psychologie und wie kamen sie dazu
diesen beruf zu wählen
ich habe in frankreich einen ferienkurs
besucht wo man die kleinen modelle eines
bildhauers französischen bildhauers nach
modellieren konnte und ab und dann hatte
ich auch kunst leistungskurs in der
schule und dann hat sich das so ergeben
und wie kamen sie zu diesem bild
eine gute frage ich weiß es ehrlich
gesagt ist wahrscheinlich durch 1000
interessen und wie kommt man zu dem
beruf in dem man in der schule geärgert
wurde und denkt man kann es besser
machen damit den schülern weil ich
gestalte ich mich interessiert habe und
dass ein ganz guter kompromiss war so
und wie kamen sie zu erarbeiten
das war schon ein großer wunsch als kind
das ganze als kind mal dass inklusion
wie sind sie chemiker geworden durch
eine ausbildung
ich glaube dass man beruflich auch mehr
machen kann als nur auf sich zu schauen
das war habe ich mich dazu entschlossen
in einem sozialen projekt zu arbeiten
was musste studieren und so einen
interessanten job zu machen wie ich
glaube ich bin eine quereinsteigerin ich
habe technik geschichte studiert das ist
das gleiche wie kunstgeschichte nun
maschinen
ich will dass immer noch studieren und
machst du dir schon gedanken über den
beruf nein nicht wirklich
und wie wird wahrscheinlich ihr job
später aussehen
ich werde wahrscheinlich
psychotherapeuten werden und warum ist
das toll
ich arbeite gerne mit menschen und ich
mache mir gerne viele gedanken darüber
warum die menschen tun was sie wollen
und was sie zu
es ist toll ich habe einen freund der
auch ein therapeut ist und es ist
wirklich hier eine freude mit ihm ein
paar bierchen zu trinken ja es ist ganz
spannend
und wie gefällt ihnen die deutsche
sprache
ich bin großer fan ich hab's ja auch
studie und was ist das schönste an der
deutschen sprache
die vielfalt würde ich sagen man kann
sehr viel ausdrücken ich war jetzt ein
jahr in england und muss sagen das hat
mich schon ein bisschen gefehlt wir
alles ein wort zu haben
also was möchtest du werden
ein gitarrist ich sehe wie würden sie
ihre arbeit konkret beschreiben was
machen sie eigentlich was ist das
erziehen das beredte die kinder auf das
berufsleben vor
und was gehört zu dem beruf was machen
sie wahrscheinlich schauspielen sie
nicht nur im film oder im theater
sondern interessante philosophische
frage ja wir schauspielern auch im leben
und können sie allen uns in kurzen
dieses projekt beschreiben war worum
geht es in diesem projekt wir
unterstützen geflüchtete menschen die
sich in deutschland selbst stand nicht
machen wollen
aber das ist toll ich habe vor kurzem
gelesen dass ein drittel der gesamten
flüchtlinge schon arbeitet und das ist
eine gute nacht ja definitiv also dass
das und der db und der rest studiert
weil das sind sehr viele junge leute
genau es gibt möglichkeiten zu arbeiten
es gibt möglichkeiten zu studieren und
selbstständigkeit ist auch ein thema und
da kümmern wir uns darum und schreiben
sie bücher meine doktorarbeit wird ein
buch deshalb ja und wenn du jetzt die
chance hätte es neu anzufangen sich
umzustellen was werde deinen berufstraum
vielleicht irgendwas mit chemie weil
chemie finde ich super
also auf jeden fall vielleicht irgendwas
mit pharmazie medizin zugezogen
ja und wenn sie die chance hätten noch
mal zu wählen würden sie noch mal gerne
bild haben werden oder vielleicht lieber
ein stuckateur lehman nicht wurde wieder
bildhauerei machen aber ich würde gleich
figürlicher kunst im studium studieren
und parallel abstrakte kunst also diese
beiden schienen figürliche kunst und
abstrakte kunst und wenn sie eine neue
chance hätten einen beruf zu wählen wird
er dass das gleiche oder also ja ich
habe jetzt tatsächlich mein studio also
mein studium anfang als sozialarbeiter
aber ja ich würde es immer wieder machen
wenn sie die chance hätten einen anderen
beruf zu erlernen würden sie also ca ja
es gibt nicht einmal das für mich ich
meine das ist mein traumberuf nichts
anderes ja es gibt andere dinge die mich
auch interessieren ja was zum beispiel
was ich zum beispiel ganz spannend
findet ist zum beispiel so otto partie
also diese ganze ist das ganze technik
dahinter
das ist das stelle ich mir erklären ich
kenne das wort
ja so so prothesen und sowas
und wenn sie die chance hätten einen
anderen beruf zu erstreben was wäre das
lehrer virtuell und haben sie sich
irgendwann überlegt vielleicht würde ich
doch gerne in anderen beruf wählen und
wenn ja was wäre das nein das ist schon
mein zweiter mein zweiter berufswunsch
ich habe vorher erzieher gelernt und
wollte dann gerne psychologin werden
warum mögen sie ihren wirt
weil
die kinder einem etwas geben was ganz
besonders ist dass es nach so viel spaß
war ein in die kleinkinder die so sechs
sieben jahre als und die haben einfach
noch mit ganz viel herz dabei die sind
so herzlich und so lieb liebevoll und
das macht einfach spaß den kindern etwas
beizubringen das ist einfach irgendwie
es in berufung lehrer zu sein
was würden sie menschen die deutsch
lernen empfehlen um deut besser zu
erleben im grunde wo kann man wenn man
schon ein bisschen deutsch spricht so
könne man die freude kriegen ja im
grunde genommen muss man sich schon mit
muttersprachlern treffen und vielleicht
irgendwie im kaffee verabreden und so
patenschaften übernehmen weil das ist
das grösste glücksgefühl gleiche man
merkt dass man was versteht was der
andere sagt vielleicht auch nicht mit
starken dialekt sprechenden hund mit ihm
zusammen sein
ich habe in baden württemberg eine
zeitige zusammen gewohnt mit koreanern
die haben da gar nichts verstanden
das war sehr frustrierend er im norden
wohnen würde ich vorschlagen
und jetzt seid ihr dran erzählt uns was
euer beruf oder euer berufswunsch ist
und wie er dazu gekommen seid hier unten
in die kommentare wir freuen uns auf
eure antworten
außerdem könnt ihr wie jede woche
interaktive übungen vokabeln und ein
transkript zu dieser episode bekommen
das ganze geht wenn ihr ein mitglied von
wisi chairman werbetafeln
darüber freuen wir uns sehr und
natürlich könnt ihr auch wie sie german
abonnieren und die klingel drücken damit
ihr immer ein
nachricht bekommt wenn wir ein neues
video hochladen
tschüss und bis zur nächsten woche